he's a superstar the most accomplished
player in our game
in history and you know he's just like
everybody else he just works extremely
hard
he's always taking care of his body he
loves his family he loves family time
and he's just cool he's real
down-to-earth guy and he's already up
there as one of my favorite teammates
and
we haven't we've only had a few
practices together so
that says a lot man i'm learning a lot
from him and hopefully be tearing up
this year
well when your last two quarterbacks for
johnny manziel and jameis winston the
bar is fairly low
as i'm just i mean sorry
how could you i mean it's mike evans
who's one of the best receivers in the
nfl
who has gotten it done with jameis
winston who
has shown flashes of being a pretty good
quarterback but he's no tom brady yeah
no this is potentially a year where mike
evans is going to hit
a new level of performance and yeah he's
got the greatest of all time who's
coming in
a guy who has never gotten in any kind
of trouble in
any circumstance other than for taking
air out of the footballs allegedly
and and you know that's as effervescent
and
and optimistic and glowing and animated
as i've ever seen mike evans he knows
what he's got
he's got himself one of the best of all
time as he tries to position himself to
get a little bit of credit
for how great he's been during his time
in the nfl chris yeah well you're right
it's finally going to put more of a
spotlight on them
and and you know we expect them to be
relevant in the playoff conversation but
again here's another great example of
just
you know what a great quarterback can do
and how his presence
just radiates you know throughout an
organization
yeah he holds himself to a standard you
know therefore the rest of the team is
going to hold themselves to a standard
let alone the coaches are going to be
allowed to hold those players to a
standard
because of the way the quarterback you
know
approaches the game on a daily basis so
this is going gonna be amazing i'm i'm
so excited to watch them play
see what they can do i mean we know the
offense is exciting
brady's arm is still damn good you know
my only concern when i think about the
tampa bay buccaneers is
no preseason games offensive line
is good not great you know brady
a little jumpy in the pocket as i've
mentioned
last year certainly and did not get that
look ooh
speed of the game get me hit in the
preseason and you get out there week one
you know and the offensive line's not
used to the speed of the game too that's
the only
hiccup i could see this offense hitting
really and i think offensive lines are
going to be handicapped as is anyways
week one of the nfl
i would tell bettors right now expect a
lot of sacks
and i wouldn't be shocked to see a lot
of quarterbacks dinged up after week one
because they haven't seen blitzers
coming full speed and fresh pass rushers
and they're not in shape to do all that
so it could lead to you know some
inconsistent offensive play there
well and i think what it's going to lead
to in tampa is the ball coming out more
quickly from what the players there are
used to and they're going to have to be
ready for that ball to be in their hands
even before they've made their break
toward
the spot where they expect the ball to
otherwise be because brady's going to
have to give her the ball more quickly
or hit the deck he's not going to want
to get hit the more he gets hit the
greater the chance he gets hurt
and you know he's going to be even if
he's nice guy
and relaxed and laid back he's
determined
determined no doubt to show he can
thrive without bill belichick just as
belichick has determined he can
show that he he'll thrive without uh tom
brady
bruce aryan's now tom brady's head coach
and look brady got cussed out from time
to time in new england and bruce arians
has cussed his guys out
from time to time here's bruce arians
talking to peter king about whether to
what extent
tom brady's getting cussed out in tampa
bay
he's got great mechanics you know he
throws with his entire body
so i was i would doubt he would ever get
a sore arm
just his mechanics were so good and uh
and how how well he takes care of
himself his foot works
meticulous and uh yeah there's there's
ton of zip on the ball he threw
a ball 60 yards the other day to scotty
miller that was on a dime
um well that lasts through december i
think so just because he takes care of
himself so much
you know we don't have any kind of pitch
counts on him um
right now he's he's one of those guys i
got to reel him in
we're not throwing in a walk-through you
know he just
get out there say wait a minute you
threw enough balls this morning all
right you just can't get it out of his
head it's had to cuss him out yesterday
yeah so did he you had to make him stop
after a while
yeah i had to call him with ugly names
and quit throwing the damn ball and walk
through
but you know the arm strength is never
going to be an issue chris you said this
before
tom brady's going to be able to throw it
like he throws it now into his 50s yeah
the question is does he have the legs to
go along with it to get himself out of
trouble right so he's in a position to
throw the ball the way that he's going
to be able to continue to throw the ball
for years
no doubt can he pop around the pocket
get his legs underneath him
is he willing to as we just talked about
sit in there and take hits to deliver
some of those throws down the field that
his arm
can still deliver hey this is one thing
you know
you know this is where i just think
people get it wrong about brady
sometimes i hear sometimes oh he's a
system he's winner he's clutch you know
he's
you know brady's arm is is an all-time
arm for me it's a great arm
he can do it with ease and like as you
heard bruce aryan say there mechanics
are good and the way he throws the ball
he is one of those guys that could throw
300 passes every day day after day after
day
and never have an issue now you can get
worn out that way and i think that's
where bruce aries is going like hey man
chill you're good you know you don't
need to throw these extra 70 balls
during the walkthrough period right now
because yeah it could take a little like
juice out of your arm if you continue to
do that all the time
but he's gonna push the envelope brady
we know he is and he's a perfectionist
that way that's what's made him great so
uh it's cool to hear those stories but i
do think that is one thing that does not
go talked about enough brady's arm
is special and it has won them games and
super bowls
it won them the first super bowl it won
them the super bowl against the atlanta
falcons
you know it almost won in the super bowl
against the philadelphia eagles his damn
arm
is really damn good and doesn't get
enough credit
and the brain is something we can't
overlook he has seen everything he said
this after they beat the falcons in
super bowl 51
several years ago you can't show me
anything i haven't seen he's going to
walk up to the line he's going to
diagnose the defense he's going to know
who's going to be open quickly and he's
going to get rid of the football yeah
quickly especially early in the season
when the offensive line is going to be
behind the defensive line
and he's going to have to worry about
somebody springing free and you know
every once in a while we're going to see
him take that
that duck and cover demeanor in order to
avoid a big hit but
it's smart at this point you know they
used to ridicule guys for it it's smart
to do what you have to do to live to
play another day especially when
these guys who are chasing you we are at
the point where they are
less than half his age he's 43
right he's gonna have 21 year olds
coming after him this year it's amazing
when you think about it
and you know when we see the the footage
of him at practice
jumping around dancing around moving
around he doesn't look like a guy who's
pulling the train into the station chris
no he looks like a guy who can keep
doing it for a while
well that's what's insane you know
sometimes i sit there and go man what
would
you know what would tom brady have been
like early on in his career
if he had trained the way he trains here
the last seven
eight years you know again you know
you've heard me we've
we've talked about that you know the way
he looked at the combine and all those
things you know at that point of his
career he was just throwing footballs
and worrying about the mental aspect of
the game and i don't think he was doing
anything else
right now he's you know as his career
evolved he started to realize wait lift
the little weights
diet you know get you know footwork
drills let me become a little bit more
of explosive as a runner and things that
he he moves better now than than he did
in 2009
or 10. you know that's what's amazing
about it and uh yeah you're right he's
he doesn't look old and you know riggity
or what do i
crickety what the hell's the word i'm
looking for out there you know
you know i think it's rickety you have
me you have me really confused though
it's not crickety no
it's rickety cricket cricket he's got a
crick in his neck or cricket you know
that's where i was
going i don't know what the hell i'm
saying crickety will be the
next page in the uh yes but uh
but yeah it's hey i he has said he's
gonna play until he's 45
the year he turns 45 that would be two
years from now that would give him three
more seasons
i'm not ready to bet the under
and if anything i i i just think he
keeps going
if he finds a comfort zone if he can
balance everything with his family
if he can convince his wife bear with me
i'm going to keep going
for a couple more i just think he's
going to keep going until he gets to
that point where he knows he can't get
rid of the football before he gets hit
and before he gets hurt
by one of those guys who will be younger
and younger and younger while he keeps
getting older and older and
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports